I remember nine years ago when I started
that alley pay people say gets don't
touch the financial sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison I call
myself like a blind man right on the
back of the blind Tigers those Esper's
riding horses they all sell we survive
we have a lot of heroes but China movies
heroes always get the American people
you will never die
if all the heroes died who want to be
the hero he's a Chinese business magnate
who's the founder of Alibaba he's the
first mainline Chinese entrepreneur to
appear on the cover of form after
graduation he applied for 30 different
jobs got rejected by all of them and
also got rejected by Harvard University
10 times he's Jack Ma and here's my take
on his top ten rule to success vol 2 and
as always guys if you hear message that
Jack has that really resonates with you
please leave it in the comments below
put quotes around it other people could
be inspired as well enjoy
[Music]
mom made it into college on his third
try and became an English teacher with
no computing or engineering background
he's an unlikely tech Titan but he said
he was captivated by the internet from
the moment he first saw it in 1995 when
he came to the US as a translator I
never touch keyboard before I was using
computer before and I say what do you
think tonight is a jack and I'll search
whatever you want on the Internet how
can I search what is such me is it just
a type I don't want to type computer so
expensive in China I don't want to
destroy it he said it's not a bomb just
the type so I touched the first two work
of beer at that time very slow come out
the American beer Japan beer in the
German beer the new China beer so I was
curious and it was typed China no China
no data came back to Hangzhou working
one dollar in my pocket scared worried
and I came back and I said I want to do
something called Internet we are not a
company that normally China Khan we call
ourselves a companies running a platform
a company that is running an ecosystem
we are almost everywhere people say Jack
you know you are in the b2b b2c and
you're calling C to be on a finance and
online payment logistic call computer
you are everywhere
not because we're greedy not because we
want to do it because we have to do it
if we cannot agree to not to do it China
accomplished in the years were collapse
I remember nine years ago when I started
that Ali pay people say yes don't touch
the financial sector because it's
illegal you may be in prison and I we
taught ourselves if we don't do it the
China newcomers who were always like us
like a chat room everybody said it's a
good thing and yeah I don't pay you
don't get the things so say well put me
in the prison let's make a shirt that
Ali pay the payment solution works
and people said the payment solutions
such a stupid idea it's a escort service
I tell you hold the money and you get
the things you pay the money if you
don't get the things you want return the
money they say it's a stupid product and
I say as long as we solve the problem I
like stupid things you know
let's make skip these things smart keep
on improving every day when I tell the
business it's so difficult to be a small
business owner in China it took me five
months to warm five on your dark and
stupid no chance and it is fitted and I
have no any idea about how to run a
business and when I go to register
company called Internet the registry
officer said no there's no such a word
into the new dictionary of your
registers and Internet you have to
register eliminating because it was the
negative computer consulting firm and I
have no idea of what is computer so I
personally have the hope computer
consulting firm it was tough we don't
know anything but enough technology we
love knowing anything about computer in
the past 15 years they working
I call myself like a blind man right on
the back of the Black Tigers those
experts right important they all fell we
survive because Primorye other future
with relief we change our self
Williamson premium every five years we
have a review of our strategy now our
strategy is always a look at the 30
years and 10 years every strategic
decisions we make we have to ask
question the disposition we make solve
society problem because we believe the
biggest social property assault the most
successful you are so if we do it this
cannot solve any social problems we
don't do it second is this project is
going to be successful in 10 years if
it's going to be successful in ten years
let's do it if it's going to be
successful in one year or one month
normally I say forget about it because
why you can be successful in one year or
one mouth so we all have to put perm and
five years ago we had a big debate about
ten years later 20 years what are the
things this China Society the world leaf
want so we say happiness and health
2h strategy so happiness and health we
believe Holly you know the movie
industry bring people happy today
nobody is happy rich people are happy
poor people know after you know at least
when I watch movie after you're happy
but right so I think we should have
partner with the Hollywood especially
like a lot of you know we have a
different way of living and in China the
movie we have a lot of heroes but China
movies heroes always that the American
people over here will never die if all
the heroes die who want to be the hero
so my movie I want to make the hero live
right so this is this is I think we
should learn a lot and it's all about
two years so we have another eight years
ago I want to make our company that it's
not ecommerce it's something that given
people inspirations given people because
I learn a lot for example I will say
that my favorite movie forest the gum
you know life stuff
this is I learned and that inspired me
that is why when people call me crazy
stupid past 70 years you're crazy I
doing something that will work
you're stupid I can't do that model
emerging this model easy this model
White Album of this model I told myself
force the gum set go ahead that would
care about what the other people and the
other thing Forrest Gump said nobody
make money out of the catcher wealth
people make money by catching shrimps so
we serve
business we studied the e-commerce
nobody believed that the China would
have in commerce because people in the
phone when she faced the face and all
kinds of networking traditional ways
there's no trust assistant in China he
had to overcome centuries of tradition
by showing Chinese buyers and sellers
that they could trust
Alibaba with their money in this new
virtual world he did it by guaranteeing
the transactions and creating his own
payment system an escrow account where
Alibaba holds the buyers money until the
goods are delivered every day we finish
more than 13 million transactions and
that means better you are buying things
from somebody you have never seen you're
getting products to the person you have
never met and there are some guys you
never know that he's going to take your
products to that place for that person I
want to tell the people that the trust
is there because it's all of us because
all about the trust who works harder
the people at eBay are the people of
Alibaba if sometimes you have not only
have to work how you have to work smart
mm-hmm so would you say you work smarter
than I may I'd have to say yes right
well it's so far yeah so far far okay
because because I think you know we are
pretty lucky people and the people to
you yeah you work very hard true in this
or the so many people work very hard but
they're not that I told my team when we
I'd pill I asked a lot of those sitting
there I think you know all of you guys
motovlog I'm millionaires and so rich
but 15 years ago who are we it's so
difficult for us to hide people fifteen
years ago people who are not that bad as
the people can walk to work on three we
hire them if nobody believes in Canada
but belief internet and they join a
company those people who believe they're
smart they were had hunted back to the
other companies
their own company those people no nobody
go to Han Kingdom this state so they did
successful there are your key reasons we
insist will persist we never give up we
believe the greens together one of
things that's so fascinating to me is
that Amazon and Jeff Bezos have pursued
what might be described as a very asset
heavy business model they're buying
airplanes they want only higher supply
chain from beginning to end and Alibaba
has effectively an asset like business
it is very much in terms of the retail
piece of this the opposite you don't
want to own the warehouses you don't
want to own the logistics companies how
do you think about that is Jeff Bezos
right or are you right and is there is
there going to be a meeting in the
middle I hope both are right and because
the world can never have a one bottle if
the world has only one correct model it
was too boring
right we need to have all kinds of
models and the people who do the bottle
should believe in the model and I
believe what I do right the difference
between Amazon and us Amazon is more
like an empire everything they should
control themselves buy and sell and our
philosophy is that we want to be a
ecosystem our philosophy is to empower
others to sell empower others to service
empower making sure the other people are
more powerful than us making sure with
our technology our innovation our
partners our 10 very small business
sellers they can compete with Microsoft
IBM
our philosophy is that we we think using
internet technology we can make every
company become Amazon
I learned my English by myself when I
was 12 years old what everything I don't
know what to tell me much
which every morning from five o'clock I
rode a bicycle at 40 minutes to the
handle hotel looking for foreign
tourists to teach in English I took
showed them around the city little
vacation my is not perfect but I think I
learned some interesting because of
thing Americans the foreign songs in
China and it told to me I'm so different
from the things on them from my parents
and my teachers I was in the Cultural
Revolution everything are taught so
different since then everything I
learned I've gotta have it you have to
use your brain to think about just a one
moment when everything is polished it
yes wait for one minute wherever's you
know wait for a minute think about a
calculator because if you look at the
world in a different way you might do in
a different one in the future pic you
will not make money but make money by
the service you offer is how hard
service you do it's going to be how
efficient you are and Alibaba we we our
company right now have 20 that's not
including the Financial Group we have 25
units to the five different business
units maybe in the future we might have
50 I don't know right we have that many
units and we are almost in every where
we control our head comes by efficiency
we have we only have to 24 to the 4,000
people I tell your story last the thing
a few products the two years ago we we
said have a budgeting meeting and I
asked my team while year 2012 if we want
to double all the numbers we have how
many people we need and people say seven
thousand eight hundred new people enter
no no no check it again and there is a
six hundred thousand eight hundred
people as you know and they might let
people ask me how many you want
that's 200 no impossible 200
my answer is our four years we discussed
we should hire more people for future
I've heard this for 10 years now let's
let let's just do the efficiency and I
told all the management if we have net
income net noodles had come over 200
even one people we should have no bonus
for a whole year for year 2012 and then
we started study plan year 2012 we never
lose 1,000 people or the number doubled
and I say if we want to create more jobs
for the others let's keep our head
accounts make sure because right now we
have over 500 million registered users
on top up no matter how many people we
are high ourselves we cannot be it's
always not enough people so we can focus
on technology focusing on making sure
the platform is efficiency focusing
everybody makes the difference in the
platform that will make the difference
able to all this is uncertain person to
world every day our system the only
certain day was yesterday I'm not sure
about that in the future
I think I would dictate I will be stupid
that's why I should retire early when
I'm young that is why I have a lot of
things that the dream I want to do I
wander throughout the day I want to be a
teacher I want to go back to school I
want to do the environment and the world
is so wonderful why should be the sea of
Oliver all the time I'm coming to this
world not to work I want to come to this
or to enjoy my life I don't want to die
my office I'm going to die on the
beaches
it's a wonderful message thank you guys
so much for watching I made this video
because royal driver asked me to do a
volume 2 on Jack Ma so if there's
another entrepreneur you'd like us to do
vol 2 arm leave in the comments I'll see
what I can do
I'm also curious to know what was the
rule that we learned the most from today
from Jack what message do we have that
really resonated with you that you're
going to immediately apply to your life
or your business somehow leave in the
comments I'm super curious to find out I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Noah socks Noah thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book here one
word
taking that picture posting it up on
Twitter you have five volts down and 45
to go so good luck on that streak Bill
Gates reads 50 books a year as well so
you're in good company thanks to the
Loveman so thank you guys all again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is much love
I'll see you soon